déjà vous avez la gare qui a une minute
à pied et elle vous même directement à
montparnasse en 25 minutes on a juste à
côté les écoles de la maternelle
jusqu'au lycée tout se fait soit à pied
soit en bus et on a une boulangerie elle
est excellente c'est parti je vous
emmène c'est une agence immobilière pas
comme les autres lagence de villepreux
utilisent un moyen bien spécifique pour
commercialiser ses biens la vidéo quand
on rencontre nos clients revendeurs on
leur propose vraiment un package qui
requiert une vidéo un reportage photo et
dans cette vidéo la ce qui est très
important c'est qu'on travaille beaucoup
avec un photographe et vidéaste et c'est
vrai qu'il ya un impact tout de suite
sur les réseaux puisqu'on a déjà une
communauté d'acheteurs qui sont déjà
présents en fait sur c'est sur ces
plateformes est un concept imaginé et
développé par cédric laporte gérant de
la société les réseaux sociaux pour nous
sont essentiels pour notre visibilité
pour notre communication pour créer du
lien également avec notre notre audience
nos grosses perfs réseaux sociaux c'est
vrai que ça permet beaucoup de choses ça
permet de montrer également son savoir
faire est également de par la vidéo le
savoir être également qui est très très
important dans les métiers de commerce
plusieurs formats sont proposés de la
présentation de biens au conseil en
immobilier en passant par des vidéos
plus légère du quotidien du personnel
par les équipes r&d qui travaille
l'équipe travail de type plutôt café
c'est pas évident les premières vidéos
c'est difficile mais maintenant c'est
pas facile on a un retour de ça parce
que comme on est une agence locale moi
les gens nous identifient plus
facilement c'est plus facile pour rod
nous interpeller aussi quand on va faire
de la prospection et
donc voilà c'est toujours sympa de
pouvoir échanger avec les gens du
secteur grâce aux méthodes de
communication modernes cédric laporte
dirige l'entreprise depuis annecy être
conseiller immobilier est pour lui une
passion en plus d'une vocation c'est
pourquoi elle y a deux ans il a lancé un
projet personnel destiné aux
professionnels du métier un moment donné
j'ai eu aussi cette envie là d'apporter
ma pierre à l'édifice à à l'immobilier
francophones en aidant d'autres agents
immobiliers à utiliser de bonnes
pratiques
l'immobilier est pour moi bien plus
qu'un métier c'est une grande passion et
cette passion j'aimerais maintenant la
partager avec toi je reste très ciblée
sur les professionnels de l'immobilier
je pense que c'est important quand on
veut réussir un projet c'est d'être très
spécifiques et de ne pas partir dans
tous les sens donc déjà la chaîne
youtube elle a pour vocation toujours de
former les professionnels de
l'immobilier d'apporter du conseil des
conseils qui touche presque vingt mille
conseillers francophones et même suivi
et repris par ses collaborateurs tout de
suite on était en adéquation avec ce
qu'ils faisaient et en fait il est
vraiment devenu une culture au sein
d'entreprises
de prendre la ses conseils pour
justement nous aider aussi à
performer et puis aussi à nous ouvrir à
d'autres types d'outils qu'on n'avait
pas l'habitude du 6 avr c'est vrai que
recevoir des messages quand je vois que
certains conseillers immobiliers ont
démarré en même temps que ma chaîne
youtube vers 2018 est aujourd'hui en
2021 2022 pardon ils ont ils ont atteint
les objectifs qui souhaitaient ils sont
heureux et épanouis dans leur métier
voilà je pense que ça c'est ma plus
grande ma plus grande récompense du
contenu réseau pour former qui ne
remplace pas le présentiel cédric la
porte se rend au moins une fois par
semestre dans son agence de villepreux
afin de faire un point et travailler
main dans la main avec ses
collaborateurs